this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm good okay all right well welcome
everyone and thanks again to all the
wonderful watershed partners that work
to get everybody here so it's really
wonderful to have you all share an
afternoon with us we'll get it on on
video and and then we'll be able to
refer back to this again let me
reiterate Carl's enthusiasm for having
all of you as partners we're always
looking to amplify our message that we
think is environmentally responsible and
and the most progressive for your
communities particularly when it comes
to sensitive areas like around
watersheds in sensitive watersheds but
I'm gonna talk to you really about how
we should be taking care of lawns no
matter where they are because if they're
in any watershed near any body of water
they can present some risk and we're
gonna want to learn how to minimize that
today big again big shout out to the
folks in Canandaigua that were
persistently trying to corral me to make
this possible in a variety of different
way so hopefully as this as maybe the
world loosens up and becomes safe again
for all of us to venture out and be with
each other maybe we'll be doing some
walk around lawns later in the
summertime in some of these watersheds I
know we're just really lucky to have so
many wonderful watersheds of beautiful
scenic lakes in upstate New York that
I'm pretty sure people are gonna hear
about soon and want to be up where it's
much less dense okay what's really
interesting for me is that if I do this
long enough a lot of the things I did
many years ago have gone back to be
relevant this was one of the very first
publications I ever worked on here at
Cornell in 1997-98 when we began to do
this work about the role Long's can play
on preserving and protecting water
quality this has always been a major
theme of our research and extension
program here at Cornell University and
this Almanac this wet this calendar
based approach has been updated a little
but still
is available for you on the cornell
website and I think the ecommons website
all right well you know it's more than
just living next to the lake it's part
of being in a watershed and as we're
learning about the way the virus is
making its way through our society we're
also learning that part of that is our
connectivity right we're connected to
each other we're connected to each other
we have to now distance itself from each
other and so now we understand that that
connection is broken well one of the
connections we simply can't break is our
connection to the watershed that our
landscape is it again be it right next
to a water body or within that watershed
right within that watershed where you
live on our street right impervious
surface a driveway a road and then
there's a sewer and typically next to
that storm drain there's a thing that
says dump no waste drains to Lake right
well essentially this means if you're
near pavement and you've got a storm
drain I would say I would venture to say
most of the storm drains in all of the
watersheds that were talking to today
except and maybe urban ones but even
urban ones drain to the lake so you
could argue everyone with impervious
surface next to their lawn has a
lakeside lawn or a surface spotty water
lawn right that you're right next to so
that's why the things we're gonna talk
about are not just for next to the lake
it's actually being part of the
watersheds that contribute to the lake
now I was really thrilled to be involved
in in a presentation before we all shut
down in February up in Canandaigua with
Kevin and Lindsay and the Canandaigua
community up there came out that was
really wonderful and one of the things I
noticed in a lot of our watersheds is we
have these mixed land uses right we have
urban land we have agricultural land we
had suburban land
we have vegetation and we have pavement
now interestingly agriculture looks to
adding buffer strips in between their
crops to minimize runoff and movement of
sediments that might come off the corn
and you ever notice the vegetation that
they use in between these rows well it's
grass usually along these little streams
that might go through an agricultural
land while there's crops on the
hillsides what's right around the water
body grass
how about deliberately creating grass
waterways or waterways to channel water
right you're not paving those things
what are you planting them - you're
planting them - grass right so clearly
grass can't be that bad and if we're
using it for these very positive things
and especially using it for these
positive things to mitigate some of the
problems that production agriculture
might create by having a fair amount of
soil exposed or a lot of paved areas new
subdivisions right what's really
critical to understand is this isn't
just a lawn issue this is everything in
every place the water comes down it's
either gonna go in the ground or run
along the surface and if it runs along
the surface eventually it's going to
make its way to a surface water body
that's just the way the hydrologic cycle
works and what we're using grass for is
to filter that water right to filter
that water to slow that water to retain
that water to allow that water to
infiltrate this is the fundamental need
for lawns in watersheds right especially
if you've got a preponderance of unlike
agriculture a lot of impervious surfaces
okay so everybody's asking the question
why have lawns and you know people make
fun of other people who like their lawns
and other people have these consensus of
you know what a lawn means to them but
I'm going I'm going all-in on lawns I'm
saying lawns are part of the United
Nations play
for us to have a healthier world and at
at the turn of the century they did a
millennium ecosystems assessment and an
ecosystem is what we're all part of
right we're all part of all the living
things around us right the living and
nonliving things around us now my
colleague and her graduate student a
number of years ago created a model for
looking at how grasses a particularly
lawn grasses turf grasses are part of
servicing us as human beings right how
does the natural world service us right
this is very highbrow stuff we're
talking about very deep science in
protecting our water bodies dealing with
climate change supporting our urban
environments with air quality supporting
our recreation and cultural heritage in
these landscapes so there's an enormous
number of benefits that we have in these
urban landscapes that means simple
things like you know you take grass out
of a very warm area hmm and you spend
more money on air conditioner right an
Arizona study found that if you're
taking out this take out the green
vegetation you can see an increase in
cooling problems in fact the Danish the
Danes in Denmark went so far as looking
and asking at people looking at
ecosystem services and asking people how
much would you pay for this how much do
you value recreation and that it looks
good how much do you value flood
protection
how much do you value traffic and noise
reduction or cooling or air purification
and this publication actually goes
through you know things like a grass
strip right or or a front garden right
and you see one of the main attractions
one of the things we seem to value the
most in that bright green part of the
bar one of the largest single parts of
the bar after flood protection is we
like the way it looks we just like the
way green grass and green infrastructure
looks right and at the same time you can
see in every case flood protection
is a big part of the services that these
green infrastructures these lawns these
parks service us with now let's hone in
specifically because we're talking about
lakeside lawn and watershed friendly
lawn let's hone in specifically on some
of the water purification and regulating
services ground water recharge pollutant
filtering these sorts of aspects that we
get from lawns all right again where are
they and they're next to paved surfaces
there was a NASA spectral imaging study
that was conducted about 15 years ago
now that looked at where all the grass
is in America and where you notice the
grass is you'll notice it's in heavily
urbanized areas and in heavily urbanized
areas you have a lot of impervious
surface now impervious surface is in and
of itself isn't an issue until you have
really wet conditions
right out in Colorado and Arizona
impervious surfaces means something very
different to them because it involves
heating right they don't get a lot of
rainfall out there for us it gets very
much involved with the way the rain
falls and if you've paid attention at
all 2018 and 2019 were two of the top
four wettest growing seasons in the
history of weather record-keeping since
1895 eighteen and nineteen were the two
wettest seasons we've among the two of
two of the five wettest seasons we've
ever had so the rainfall comes down in
very short intense amounts this is
making the problem worse not only are we
getting wetter but the weather
conditions are such that the amount and
intensity of the amount of high
intensity events is increasing as you
can see pretty significantly from this
particular data source we are getting
more intense rain events which is going
to make the need for retaining that
water more important now you take the
intensity of the rainfall with what
happens when we put paved ground down
right what happens when the city in
Canandaigua develops more what happens
when we develop more around Lake
Chautauqua what happens more when we
develop more of the lakefront at Seneca
we Seneca Lake oh we put new
subdivisions that drain in and we begin
to increase the amount of impervious
surface right well when we do that there
just isn't any place for the water to go
you can see that the runoff is going to
increase dramatically from you know
natural ground cover to high density
residential you're going to 55 percent
runoff four to ten percent runoff from
very high infiltration to a very low
infiltration and so this is very
critical to understand when you're
thinking about a watershed because what
we need is more natural ground cover
that allows the water to penetrate so
that the Hutchinson River Parkway where
I grew near where I grew up didn't flood
right just like that water that would go
to the Parkway this was a movie I took
just the other day when that 2 inch
rainfall came through Tompkins County
and you see that call yeah we can see it
so this was about it this was the early
start of a two inch rainfall and you can
see the water flowing nicely and looking
back on my lawn there at the farm
uh and now I went and took a picture up
sorry and this is what the lawn looked
like you can see throughout the lawn
here the standing water this means that
the soil is saturated you can see more
standing water here it doesn't matter
even if you don't do anything to your
lawn when this amount of water moves
over it all the contaminants at the top
of that soil at the top of that grass
move into the lake it doesn't matter if
the soil isn't allowing the water to
penetrate if the soil is wet if the
grass isn't dense enough to stop it from
getting to the lake it doesn't matter
what you do what's on that top is what's
on the top of that lawns gonna go so
that's why you'll hear me say sometimes
the best thing to do is don't apply
anything people like well should I say
test and fertilize should I put my
pre-emergence no no what you need is a
dense vegetation let's not start with
what you need to apply let's start with
what your lawns supposed to be doing and
work backwards from there all right well
what does research tell us well research
tells us that in fact when you look at
volume of runoff total volume of runoff
not what's in it but the total volume of
runoff you can see that wooded lots and
low-maintenance turf where there's bare
ground exposed or opportunity for water
to move along a surface you're going to
see a higher volume of runoff at least
in this study that was done in the Kouga
Lake watershed now what have we learned
what did they learn from this 5-year
study well it didn't matter what kind of
law you had if you don't have a lot of
plants on it and then the soils are wet
the water moves OH
right so we're gonna talk a little bit
about how you fix these things first
they were most significant during
establishment why is that because the
soils exposed because the plants aren't
there right that's the problem
production agriculture has when they got
a plow and plant like they're doing now
we get this two inch rainfall that's
gonna come through Sunday Monday and all
that muds gonna try to make its way to
the lakes that's why we put in these
buffer strips so that the grasses can
trap it and then finally phosphorous
runoff is purely a function of runoff
volume it really doesn't have a lot to
do with fertilizer but we can tell you
you don't need to put any more
phosphorous on your lawn in fact
virtually none of your lawns in our neck
of the woods are going to need
supplemental phosphorous especially if
they've been on established on that lawn
for more than five years alright so what
I've been honing in on is let's we're
not even gotten to take care of the lawn
yet what was the lawn do it well the
lawn is helping you filter and there's
no question about the fact that the
kinds of vegetation along the lake that
can retain water that prevents
vegetative material from getting into
the water that stops you from applying
things into the water that filters water
before it goes into the lake are always
going to be the best thing to do they're
not always easy to manage this garden is
a lot harder to manage at times than a
lawn that all you got to do is cut right
and then if you're gonna leave a buffer
strip right you're gonna have a little
meadow here you know that it's not that
doesn't just happen like this this is
something that probably takes four or
five years of pretty dedicated planting
and establishing that a lot of people
don't want to do but having something
even if it's a dip before it gets to the
lake to hold the water if you're right
by the lake right if you're right by the
link for a buffer strip all right so
let's go through some very simple
tactics that we've designed around
science and research that we think are
going to help everybody how
Lon they can be satisfied with and do
the best they can for the environment
Laurie brew and I worked on this many
years ago with my colleague Mary thorne
and developed a very simple approach to
this now there's four steps that we said
to success of course we took the four
step thing from Scott's right Scott's
has the four step program and we thought
maybe that would be court sort of cute
one of the things you will notice is
applying fertilizer is not one of the
four steps to success all right what's
the first step no your lawn right how do
we know what do we know about what's
going on with our grass how does it grow
most of you have probably noticed it's
the middle of May appear in upstate New
York
and maybe of mode once maybe twice I had
two inches of snow on the ground the
other day so I'm not sure how it's going
for everybody else up here but for sure
we haven't really got that flush of
growth yet but roots are actively
growing and that should that's a good
sign because the deeper the roots can
grow and mine the soil for nutrients
right the less you have to do it's it's
supplying its own water it's supplying
its own fertilizer by grabbing it out of
that reservoir that we call the soil
right and you see as the plant goes
through the year it changes the way it
grows now you can't know your lawn if
you don't your soil
okay your lawn in soil and almost
everybody thinks that mean they should
soil test and find out what nutrients
they need and I'm here to tell you it
has a lot more to do with the physical
properties is it compacted do the roots
grow in it does it drain does it puddle
when you fall then you crack your head
open can you put a screwdriver in it
however you can describe the physical
attributes of your soil they are
fundamentally more important than
chemical properties if you can get a
soil to start and sustain some plant
growth especially grass growth if you
look in this
I'd of a 200 year old soil pit down at
the Greenwood Cemetery in Brooklyn right
this is about 200 years of organic
matter in the soil and you can see at
the very top how nice and dark the soil
is but as you get closer to the rock
that is the earth right
you see there's much less color down
here it's grayer it's clay it might be a
sand vein in here
here's some iron silt settling in but up
here this is where the action is at the
top is where the biological activity is
that's where the microbes are chewing on
that organic matter the plant material
look at the roots in here all that stuff
is food for the microbes that keep your
soil alive keep it functioning properly
and keep you needing to do very little
if it will sustain plant growth if you
can get grass to grow in a soil it will
improve that soil if your soil is
compacted or you know rocky that the
plants can't grow into it those kinds of
things will be very difficult to sustain
a healthy lawn without having to apply a
lot of things listen I can grow a lawn
on a soil that's an inch thick I can do
it but I got to do more things I've got
a it takes more to sustain it if I let
the plants mine the soil deeper I won't
need to do as much I won't need to apply
as much in many cases I could get by
which is mow in half the time ok so
what's happening what's happening is the
organic matter is building at the
surface now what is organic matter
organic matter is the stuff that used to
be to green stuff on top or the root
roots below it's just the plant material
that slocks off and falls into the soil
microbes start to break it down like
anything else dead and dying and as
they're doing that they're chewing on it
and pooping out nutrients so they're
chomping it down and releasing nutrients
that is more active
when the soils are warm and wet so a
warm wet soil will actually fertilize
itself right you shouldn't need much
supplemental fertilizer now you will
know you will know if you have to
fertilize primarily based on the age of
your lawn another good example you know
I'm getting older and little wiser so
that's good with age lawns get better
with age
an aging lawn builds that organic matter
up at the surface right this this
organic matter up at the surface right
some people call it thatch a little
bit's okay
too much is no good if you over
fertilize you've got a thatch problem if
somebody's trying to sell you a lot of
thatch management problems a lot of
thatch management remedies it's like
because you're over fertilizing
eventually thatch gets mixed into the
soil worms
core cultivation however you do it it
becomes part of the soil and again that
overtime can supply all the nutrients
the plants need provided the soils warm
and wet now as the soils begin to warm
over the next couple of weeks which
they'll do very rapidly soon you will
see that the lawns will green up without
having to fertilize them and that is
because over time the concentration of
nitrogen the primary nutrient for growth
now that we're all curve experts right
eventually it grow it increases and then
it levels off and at this level that's
all the nutrients your lawn needs so as
your lawn ages
you should Sneed less fertilizer now new
lawns in the Almanac we go through a
pretty simple step guide but how to do
it this is important if you want to
change grasses maybe you did some
construction maybe you want to do some
regrading to fix some drainage when that
soil is exposed its presents a greater
risk to the watershed so the quickest
thing to do
to get it planted and covered either
with seed or sod and get it established
rapidly now what should you plant now
interests you know there's four years
we'd recommend Kentucky bluegrass and as
we've started to think about maybe we
want to do less we see many prominent
Kentucky bluegrass varieties simply do
not do as well when you don't fertilize
them regularly however you find other
grasses that will do very well in our
climate turf type tall fescues and you
can see how well they'll do without any
fertilizer and a lot of it is because
they're deeper rooted and more
accustomed to needing less nutrients now
now that you know your lawn what are the
adjustments you want to make number one
blade the mower blade the single most
important thing you do that as I learned
again this morning from a colleague at
the Ohio State University is stressful
mowing is stressful so you don't want to
do it a lot you want to make sure the
grass doesn't grow too fast so you don't
want to fertilize it a lot when you go
out to mow you want to make sure the
blade sharp you want to mow higher we're
gonna talk about that in a minute
leave the clippings there leave the
clippings now if you have a lawn that
grows a lot and it's gonna clump or if
you have pets and kids that are tracking
the clippings inside and you want to
pick them up you certainly are better to
do that and blow them in the street or
blow them in the lake okay pick them up
and put them in your compost pile take
care of your tree leaves in the fall the
best place for your tree leaves is right
back in your lawn right back in your
lawn long-term studies looking at
mulching tree leaves in too long to have
not found a negative effect and finally
if you have bare ground the best thing
to do is seat it maybe this is the year
you skip the pre-emergent crabgrass you
skip the weed and feed and you just go
straight to seed just go out and buy a
big bag of lawn seed that'll come up
quick and throw it on your lawn get the
ground covered try to get the best
varieties you can find talk to your
garden center people
about the kinds of grasses they
recommend but it's much better to get
things planted and growing than right
away going to using a pre-emergent
herbicide now when it comes to mowing
one of the things we're promoting is
raising your high t'cut we're talking to
our commercial people about this a lot
because of maybe reduced work force
right so let's look at how different it
is if you mow at two inches that means
following the one-third rule right the
one-third rule means you should never
mow more than thirty percent of the leaf
tissue a single mowing
never take off more than thirty percent
so if you're keeping it at two inches if
your mower set at two inches make sure
you cut it when it's at three inches
that's about once a week three inches go
to four and a half inches that's about
every ten days and if you bow all the
way to four inches you might be able to
get by with mowing once every 14 days
now if you consider most of us look at
our lawns we rarely even walk on it if
walk on it it's a very small area there
shouldn't be a reason why we can't mow
higher and the higher we mow and the
less frequently we mow the deeper the
roots go into the soil and as they go
deeper into the soil again you'll need
to apply and do less things to your lawn
all right spring the spring feed is
stamp the keynote part step three right
if you've got a good thick lon isn't
need to fertilize again however if your
lawn has been thin you can see bare
ground this is a good time to get some
fertilizer to make it thick so it can
hold the water as it might be passing
through or allow the water to infiltrate
better grasses will improve the
infiltration of the soil if you can get
grasses growing on their soils the
infiltration will improve and the water
will infiltrate in and not make its way
along the surface taking every
thing with it to the lakeside okay so
what about alternatives to lawns this is
becoming a very popular approach we're
actually talking about this tomorrow on
a webinar that we're doing with an
expert on planting clovers and lawns
this is becoming a much more popular
approach certainly something that allows
you to reduce your fertilizer use
because clover fixes nitrogen from the
atmosphere and supplies it to the lawn
so having a nice dispersed patch of
clover like this can really be a nice
lawn alternative it seems to also help
with drought stress which is a very
positive benefit as well all right let's
go through some very quick little tips
highlighting some parts of the lakeside
lawn care work that's already underway
with some of the watershed folks first
there are regulatory things you need to
pay attention to right there are laws
that govern how we handle and fertilize
our lawn so first no lawn phosphorus
right you shouldn't buy a lawn
fertilizer that has a second number
that's other than zero I don't care if
it's organic or synthetic should not buy
a bag of fertilizer until your lawn turn
so purple you're wondering wow I've
never seen my lawn turned this purple
that is an indication you probably need
some phosphorous but until then it's
very unlikely any of us will need
phosphorous supplementally applied to
our lawn now just figures we're not
fertilizing doesn't mean the plant
doesn't need it it means the soils got
plenty of it right again
you can't fertilize between December and
April first right and please if you're
gonna spill it clean it up this is a
very common phenomenon we see throughout
the urban areas in the springtime and
then this is the trickiest part within
20 feet of any water body or ten feet of
trees and shrubs taking care of these
edges is the trickiest part of this deal
every aspect of our industry struggles
with it golf courses
school districts that have water bodies
of course homeowners and things like
that managing these buffer strips is
very tricky best to err on the side of
not doing something and trying to keep
it as dense and vegetated as possible
again highlighting some of the great
work done in Canandaigua now simple
things mower blade sharp don't cut it
low leave the clippings on so glad to
see the watershed Commission's adopting
these wonderfully smart simple ways of
taking care of your lawn now in our
little guide we say listen grass might
not be right for everybody it might not
be the right plant for everybody and so
what kinds of alternatives are out there
and that's where you start thinking
about you know shade maybe it's too
shady and you different plants maybe
along the edge of the the of the lake
you want some different plants maybe
there's a walkway maybe it's time to put
a walk path in there so I think there
are very different ways of looking at
places that we typically have lawns that
maybe we should consider alternative and
and these include shade pads and steep
slopes
all right couple of simple tips maybe we
don't think about tree leaves
present an enormous nutrient problem to
the watersheds every time the true shed
their leaves onto the pavement or berate
them to the side of the road and the
town's coming maybe pick them up two
weeks after we raked them there
if we're lucky depends on where you live
we're letting the nutrients in those
tree leaves leak to the storm water
every time freezes and thaws and rains
and rains by and those tree leaves are
exposed on the pavement to the storm
drain they're gonna contaminate the lake
with nutrients if you're fertilizing or
applying anything and you're using a
rotary spreader be sure to clean it up
you may be consider using a drop
spreader feel like you have to make an
application of course dealing with the
clippings it's really not smart just
blow them onto the street we
see this very common and of course pet
waste this doesn't have as much to do
with your lawn but this is the place
where I tell you hey tell them look you
know get your pet to do it on the grass
somewhere or clean up after your pet but
certainly pet waste contributes a
significant amount of nutrients and
contaminants to any watershed now for
those of you that were just well you
know how do I get a company to help me
do this here are some questions to ask
that we have in our Cornell guide first
are they gonna test the soil now you
might have got an inside little tip here
they may say yeah I test your soil and
then you can say well are you going to
test the physical properties cuz I heard
this guy at Cornell says the physical
properties are important and that's a
good way of measuring whether a lawn
care service really knows what they're
doing because the physical properties by
far are much more important than any
chemical test now when they do that can
they share the results what about these
materials what kinds of products do you
use are you gonna do you have the
ability to come and you know decide
whether I need a pest pesticide before
you make the application and are you
willing to customize your treatment
based on my conditions listen I don't
necessarily need organic but I only
think I want this little patch of this
area fertilized so you certainly want
somebody who's gonna work with you and
maybe somebody that also you've talked
to your neighbors and have had some
success with I really like the pledge
that you they they you go to the
Canandaigua lake friendly lawn care site
and and it keeps popping up they want
you to pledge they want you to get some
skin in the game and it's really
important that we do that and I really
think it's important that we open
ourselves up to third-party review I
really like that citizens are willing to
say Here Come and I'm willing to adjust
what I do for the greater good and boy
if there isn't a better time to think
about the greater good now is that time
so if we can think about it for our
health and well-being around a global
pandemic maybe we can think about it
with common sense and simple things like
keeping our surface water bodies and
beautiful lakes up
preserved and healthy and we can all
have nice garden parties on our lawn and
still have a half way and still way have
a beautiful lawn that keeps the
watersheds safe and sound thanks to
everybody for joining Carl what kinds of
questions are we talking about now yeah
so we got a couple good ones there's one
thing the scaleless Lake Association
they're asking about what considerate
considerations should be made when
they're transitioning from turf to
meadow area especially if you have
existing turf trying to convert that to
a meadow meadow area
I'm guessing they may not want to use
herbicides so maybe we could focus on a
non pesticide version of doing that and
then maybe also providing that
alternative as well well listen the
quickest way to get a meadow going would
be to actually get some live plants and
start planting it in Scout the
vegetation down you know what you're
trying to do listen this is just this is
a competition this is a competition
between what you want to grow and what's
there the easiest way to win is to spray
a chemical on it and kill what's there
and if you don't want to do that you
have to find other ways of weakening
what's there without creating new weed
problems and getting the plants you want
established so that transition might
take longer if you try to go through
seed and planting so depends on how big
your gonna do it if it's going to be a
large-scale meadow there really isn't
any way other than to expose as much
soil as you can get that seed down there
and then I think you can use mowing
depends on the plant material that you
plant but mowing affords you some
options and there also are some spot
treating organic knock backs you can use
but it will be more labor intensive and
take my opinion a good meadow really
doesn't start to mature until the third
year and you're really not seeing what
its going to be until the fifth year if
you're really serious about something
that probably is going to be multi
species with grass and forbs
and then something that you could mow
once or twice a year and and and
provides enormous ecosystem services
especially when it comes to pollinator
habitat as well as watershed benefits
yeah and say another couple questions
from Tim Johnson who you asking about
leaves if he mulches leaves into the
line does the pH of the lawn change does
he have to add lime based on if you're
mulching the leaves into the lawn yeah
you know that's the pretty common wisdom
Carl and Tim that that you know tree
leaves somehow are screwing up the lawn
now and I'm not talking about pine
needles I'm not necessarily talking
about pine needles but I'm talking about
deciduous trees and scientists at
Michigan here at Cornell in Indiana at
Purdue have looked at oak maple ash
they've looked at three different types
of leaves and in general over a long
period of time have seen really no
negative effects I'm talking like five
to ten years studies no effect on pH no
effect on rooting no effect on soil
nutrient levels that were causing
problems it just doesn't seem like tree
leaves are that big of a deal and I'd
say even further anecdotally because I
spent a lot more time in golf course
rough than Carl does I see a lot of golf
course rough that gets mulch treating
tree leaves mulched in it for the last
50 years because guys aren't picking
them up they're just running the mower
over and mulching them in and they've
been like that for 20 or 30 years with
virtually no supplemental nutrients
required so I know that there's
conventional wisdom about these things
but I don't I don't see any negative
effect the only problem is it's hard to
do it's like you have to look at your
you have to look at your lawn like a
shag rug you know all the crumbs that
you're spilling the shag rug will get to
the bottom and no one will see them
right if a long shaggy rug but if you
got a short rug you're gonna see every
single crumb that falls on it so it's
really good to give yourself that 3 inch
turf there in the fall to mulch those
leaves into
so that they've got a place to go
because if they're shaving the ground
then they create then they create other
kinds of problems for the grass growing
and disease great and so on those lines
you also mentioned mulching the
clippings of the lawn back into the
lawns or not removing the clippings we
also mentioned pal those clippings
getting into the water can can cause
water quality issues what exactly is it
about the clippings is there something
in there that's that's making it bad to
go into the water but good for us to
leave on the lawn yeah it's the
nutrients it they're basically the best
way to think about grant a grass plant
is it's a it's a three one two
fertilizer all the grass clippings if
you collected your grass clippings from
your lawn it's essentially three percent
nitrogen just around one percent
phosphorous and two percent potassium
right those are the three biggest comply
everything else is minor after that
calcium is in there magnesium the minor
in and as far as amounts go you you
would say so in a in a lake
that's like fertilizing the lake and we
don't want to do that and in a lawn it's
like fertilizing the soil and Psyche
whoa I want to do that and that's how we
can say very clearly that lawns can be
sustainable because if there is a
reservoir of nutrients in the soil and
every time you cut all you do is return
those clippings to the ground nothing's
happening to those nutrients unless they
are flushed along the surface or leached
out if the soil drains excessively but
generally the organic matter
concentrations in these soils are so
high they hold on to all these nutrients
so we think over time clippings are
easily the best way to just reduce your
fertilizer use 25-30 percent Carl
yeah in a lot of ways it kind of closes
the loop on the system right so we need
to move that those clippings okay now
there's you know you're depleting the
nitrogen bank from the soil so we got a
couple questions about moss and I think
you know a lot of lakeside lawns there's
probably some trees in the area shade
that can be that can give you some
pretty significant moss issues people
are wondering how they could if they
have moss
right now how could they transition to
turfgrass a little bit more you know
with all the considerations being a
lakeside long
yeah for sure listen you know if there's
moss there there's got to be some some
soil exposed and generally Carl is right
you tend to see it begin in shaded areas
where grass has a tough time growing
compacted soil surface rooted trees just
a lot of places where the grass isn't
competitive I mean it really isn't any
other explanation for it and in fact
this is an odd thing that happens on
putting greens you wouldn't believe it
golf courses have problems with moss
because as soon as a little ball mark
doesn't get fixed right not like any
member at Canandaigua Country Club never
doesn't finish their ball mark but when
the ball mark doesn't get fixed within a
matter of two to three weeks algae
starts to grow and within a matter of a
month you could have a patch of moss
there so moss really is an indication of
the competitiveness of the grass number
one which is typically affected by light
number one and number two poor drainage
or compacted soils now it doesn't make
sense to try to do anything if you're
not fixing one of those two problems I
could tell you hey go in there and plant
some grass but if it's not gonna get any
more light and the soil still crappy you
know you're gonna be back to moss in a
few years so what I would say is that
why do I have this Moss right how do I
fix that and then once you fix that
except the ways of getting grass or or
or another vegetation like pachysandra
or IV or hosta or the million stupid
things to grow in shaded environments
other than grass that's probably the
best way to go now all that said if
you've got some grass and some moss and
it looks like the grass just needs a
little help you can buy chelated iron
you can spray chelated iron that you can
get in any big box your garden center
store they'll sell you put it on the end
of your hose and you can spray it on
there and you'll have to do it a number
of times but that'll do two things it'll
turn your lawn greener and it'll also
weaken and eventually kill the moss and
hopefully
that will combined with the better soil
and some more light give you a better
walk nice so we also have a question
kind of the same effect when persons ask
me about maybe having some more clover
in their lawn trying to convert from
established grass long to have some
clover in it I don't have any comments
on that Frank I know tomorrow we're
gonna speak to a pageboy graduate
students actually studying this on
another webinar but any comments for me
on that yeah I mean I can I can tell you
that we've purposely been trying to
plant clover over the last couple of
years for one particular reason where we
see a large amount of clover we don't
see crabgrass there seems to be a direct
relationship between a dense stand of
clover and lack of crabgrass and so
we've actually been trying to plant it
in two places and I've been really happy
in general if there's bare ground it may
not come up right away but if you get it
planted roughly around the time you
plant grass seed you'll see it come up
and you know where where where we've
planted some out in Martha's Vineyard
call Chris sicko calls them the feeder
plots cuz the geese like they seem to be
very popular with some of the waterfowl
out there but we've had an enormous
amount of success really just planting
clover the way we plant grass make sure
the ground is you know that the seed can
get in contact with the soil you don't
need very much we're talking about you
know ounces per lawn I mean if you
bought a couple of vials of it it would
be enough because one of the problems
clover has and when I take this up with
Paige tomorrow everything is really nice
for clover the first couple of years and
then it doesn't play nice anymore then
they oh I want to take over and it gets
patchy and maybe and that can be okay
but not if you're gonna play sports and
other sorts of things on it but for
lawns I love I think the more we begin
to return to embrace clover the better
off we're going to be but one more thing
Carl once you plant the clover it makes
it controlling other weeds a little more
difficult so that that does you know if
you want clover but you don't want
dandelion yeah you're gonna have to be
careful about the things you do from
and so Steve's got a good question here
he's asking about buffer zones you know
talking about row crops but also on
roadside ditches is there like a minimum
you know length of buffer zone we should
have for those types of areas and do you
think there should be right there should
be regulations watershed regulations
mandating that you have buffers when
you're getting up to against a stream or
roadside ditch I think there are in fact
minimum distances Carl I actually think
the runoff law does give that guidance
about 25 feet and I think we've included
that in our golf BMPs over the years for
water quality protection so I do think
there are minimum levels and actually
there's been a fair amount of research
looking at how to manage the grass in
that 25 foot buffer because you know you
can't let it thin out and you don't want
it to necessarily depends on how it is
you don't want it to look ratty so there
is a set you know that transitional area
of every landscape is always going to be
tricky to manage now do I think we
should regulate it put well I'm of two
minds on this one is you know why have
laws no one's going to enforce you have
people going around writing well you
don't have a buffer ticket that's one
thing that bugs me is they're difficult
to enforce on the up side regulations
change behavior if there's a law and I
can give this talk and say you have to
do this and you have to do that I can
tell you I got a better chance of
changing people's behavior but again in
the absence of enforcement you know
we're really having to rely on people
thinking about their lawn as a greater
good as a as a part of their community
that they're connected to not just their
lawn some kind of another question along
those lines Tammy's asking about
alternatives to paved driveways and I
know a lot of times when I see houses on
the lake there's a real steep driveway
because you know they're right on the
edge of the lake it could be a gravel
driveway a paved driveway and obviously
you talk about you know those surface
impervious surfaces that lead to runoff
what could you do to help around that
are there alternatives maybe dragway
why's that
sure sure there are obviously there's
pervious pavement
there's pervious concrete we've started
to put these at Cornell now we've got it
up at the hospital grits it's basically
composite material
you know pavement material where the
fine particles have been removed so you
put the rocks down and then you spray a
epoxy on it and you know the thing is
you got to remember you can't you can't
you can't sand it you know you can't
because it seals it up and then it won't
it won't drain so you've got to be
careful about how you do that so so
pervious concrete pervious pavement if
you you know you're on a steep hill and
you need traction there certainly are a
growing number of grass paving systems
that have various levels of success I
can tell you honestly to have various
levels obviously the flatter they are
the better they work the less you have
to have traction and the worst part
about driving on any kind of a living
substance is is when you turn the
shearing of the tire creates a lot of
the biggest problems so the pervious
surface the permeable concrete a bit
more expensive but but obviously will
significantly increase infiltration and
and and then theoretically get into the
ground and and do that better I don't
think it's realistic to have a grass
driveway if you've got a steep slope and
I don't think any of the grass paving
systems are going to necessarily really
work in a steep situation there are
there are rubber options but nothing
that's mainstream that's for sure so a
couple of questions here about weeds and
John's asking specifically about
dandelions he would we consider that
healthy lawn growth maybe you could
comment a little bit about you know
weeds and lakeside lawns should be
controlled in are they okay there there
shouldn't weeds we might be more or less
willing to remove maybe talk about that
a little bit the interesting study there
was an interesting study that showed
Marty's work found that when he had some
dandelions on it
there was actually some less runoff
dandelions actually improved the
permeability of the system and if you
think about the root of dandelion you
might understand how it's actually
providing some increased infiltration
maybe even traffic some water weeds a
perennial weed if it if it plays nice
with other plants no problem
perennial weed that dominates and
becomes a monoculture to the point of
invasiveness that gets to be a problem
because if one thing comes in and takes
it out now I'm out of luck I don't
really know how to grow something that
just moves in like that and then just
dies stiltgrass as an example of
something like that that could just come
in take over and you won't have anything
else and and so I would say the last
part of this is is really just annual
weeds if I have bare ground annual weeds
are a bad actor because they're only
going to be there they're a fair-weather
friend they germinate in a spring they
give you some good you know growth or in
a summer and then a fall
they die and you got bare ground through
the winter and spring right when you
need vegetation to be doing its job so
the one of the most important things for
us to realize is perennial weeds and
lawns in many cases are more about
aesthetic preferences potential
allergies watching out for a potential
invasiveness but it's really the annual
weeds that only exploit an area when
it's bare come up die-off and now I got
bare ground again so getting that area
to fill in with with fertilizer getting
that area filled in with seed to me has
to be the paradigm shift that lawns have
to experience we have to think about
reimagining lawns with some weeds and
without weed and feed and I don't think
it's gonna be that hard it's just
different that what we've always done
Scots has done a hell of a damn job in
getting everybody to believe this must
be done yeah yeah so and I think one
thing that's important to point out we
talk about it's bad that the soul
runs off and gets into the water and
some people might be here saying well
you know it's just just dirt you know
what's so bad about dirt there's a
couple reason why that's bad in you know
Lakes the first reason is it's just
total dissolved solids light has to move
through the water to get to certain
species and to keep the ecosystem the
way it is in a lake once you start
throwing dirt in there okay now the
light is not getting through the water
profile so well that's one reason the
next reason is soil particles contain
phosphorus right Frank and faster this
is a big limiting nutrient that causes
the algal blooms and that's the stuff
that we're seeing increases in as years
go on so soil you know you might think I
had to start well you know what's so bad
if it gets in the water
well settles right you know Carl it
affects the light penetration but then
as it settles there's less volume of
water which means you know now to Lake
when it floods if they don't get the
levels right it's flooding up into my
kitchen yeah right so yeah I mean the
prac there isn't really a purpose for
Long's beyond the erosion
I mean if you didn't if you didn't care
about keeping the soil in place why
don't you play a corn on the edge of the
Lyne I mean to me this is a fundamental
problem that Agriculture's been trying
to address with no-till systems and
reduced tillage systems is not
disturbing that soil for the reasons of
climate change but also the increased
a-road ability the advantage that lawns
have is their perennial and I'm done
you know parsing well what about you
know crack grass in there and what about
dandelion in there what about clover am
i great I just care that it's dense
because I don't really like you
blanketing the whole lawn now blanketing
the lawn with pesticides if you elicit
if you've got some dandelions and they
bother you go get a squirt bottle and
squirt the day you don't even have to
pull it just squirt it so it drips and
you're done you don't have to spray the
whole lawn right so even if you want to
have fewer weeds just go out and spot
treat that's a responsible way to manage
some of these problems
now I'll paint it all rosy you don't
want to put pesticides on you got a
history of grub problems man you are Sol
you are down the river without a paddle
all of a sudden the raccoons appealed
back everything and all the ecosystem
services of that lawn have gone to help
so if you have a history of soil insects
grubs you know that and not just the
insects but that the vertebrate animals
come and peel the lawn back right there
may be some value to spot treating
insecticides but again I I can't tell
you exactly where to do what our
entomologist can't tell you exactly
where to do it and maybe the best thing
to do is you know just okay they peeled
it up try to plant it back and get grass
or reefs on it as quick as you can
and until we get a better solution for
controlling grubs there really isn't
anything effective I could recommend to
a homeowner beyond an insecticide and
all of them are pre-emerge you know pre
oh no the lawn business has become a pre
with no one wants to bother with their
lawn so just put stuff on so you don't
have problems you know now Scots has
made a triple power thing with the
fertilizer the insecticide and the
herbicide in it all at one and yeah I
mean that's one way to go but not if
you're concerned about the quality of
the water as it's moving across your
lawn so we're bumping up against the
hour that deadline here it's still a lot
of questions but I think the one we
should end on is sometimes asking about
if they can have a runoff consultants
someone advise probably on a
site-specific
level Frank anybody you could think of
or they're Cornell Extension people
you'd reach out to yeah I would reach
out to my watershed councils I believe
there are probably trained watershed
scientists like Kevin and Lindsay who
know a lot about how to work with
homeowners because I've spent my life
trying to avoid talking to homeowners I
study I study grass and I work with
professionals and so the consumer 'king
in the consumer market and working on an
individual site-specific basis is a
wonderful service
I do it I don't know if they provide but
the ability to sort of have these
site-specific decisions some help with
that is is really important so I mean
I'm sure there I gotta tell you and I'm
sure there are extensive sources this
probably I know you know Rebekah
Schneider studies ditches so I'm sure
there's people in the ditch world that
could tell you about this
we have limnology here at Cornell that
study lakes and we can probably get you
more information about that but it's not
it's like no one's gonna stop driving
cars once the global pandemics over and
no one's getting rid of wholesale their
lawns and so how do we have lawns that
make sense for the world that we live in
now where we care about the quality and
health of our lakes and our communities
yeah it's good that you mentioned
Rebekah Schneider's work we put a link
JoEllen lament of New York State IPM put
a link in there for people asking about
roadway ditches she's done a lot of work
at Cornell studying that so you can
check her out
so with that you know we're an hour here
Frank a ton of questions thanks
everybody for joining really well
attended it seems like people really
have an interest in this stuff thanks
for giving us a run down and what a lawn
is what it provides the ecosystem
services and then we've got a lot of
discussion about you know things to
think about when we're caring for our
lawn so with that in behalf of Cornell
University everyone really thanks a lot
for being with us today thanks to Kevin
and Lindsay for helping put this on from
the Canandaigua like you this summer
hope we get to walk around some lake
sides this summer to everybody take care
thanks Carl everybody see you guys guys
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu